You're strange. After the match with your sister, you
didn't lie about anything in particular, and Lelia was too scared to approach you. It's even
more unbelievable than anything else. That
match was for Claire. That's
why.  And I
don't have the right to be Claire-sama's aunt anymore.
What are you doing to me? I'm not something.
What on earth are you thinking?
Don't you actually feel good, like Manaria-sama?  He was
wanted by a wonderful person and was his
first love, a prince.
Correct me. I
don't think he lost because he yelled abusive words at her like a child, and then he got upset and ran away.
Now you're my main person,
and I can't help but think that I'm quitting.I'm
quitting being Claire-sama's maid.I know you mean it.I've
had a lot of complaints, but so far.  I would like to
thank you for being such a sacred place in France for making good use of it.
Thank you, Mr. Taylor
[Music] Mr.
Flare, you are now grown up, and I am
sorry for being selfish until now. I wish you all the
best in the future, Mr. Taylor.
I made a mistake, and I'm
sorry. I made a
fatal mistake that can't be undone.
You're going to leave me alone too
. [Music]